she has okay good morning everyone good
morning Millennials I have returned back
to home planet with Intel from the
Midwest and I couldn't believe I was in
the Midwest like I had no idea that's
crazy
Chicago's nothing yeah Minnesota is the
Midwest totally like Midwest just like
Dress Barn you know what I mean TV you
go no like it was glamorous as hell I
was not a Midwest wow how were your
travels my travels were extremely
treacherous like literally in Chicago it
was almost 100 degrees and the weather
said it felt like 108 so like you know
me like the first two days I was there I
literally went from air-conditioned uber
to hotel to a restaurant like I never
spent more than like a minute outside
then I decided to go to a baseball game
and like the trip wasn't the same
you know it was a big mistake famous
famous a huge but the shows were great
the first horse shows were in downtown
and they were so lit like I just really
feel like I'm really coming into like my
comedic style do you know name you are
coming they were there were growth shows
like I was really growing I'm like
taking liberties with my show artistic
liberties yeah and then we moved to the
bigger venue in the suburbs which I was
like living for all the extra space in
my green room and they had like better
snacks and that was where like you know
the the suburbia was like the moms the
kids it was that one was 18 plus so
there was a lot of like kids there who
were having to drink the mocktails it
was really it was great like of all of
your travels which comedy club at first
no gue you enter Nashville which comedy
club has the best screamer Janey's
Nashville you were there okay oh my god
I keep every day image I go to because
both my shows are at Zanies I'm like
where's the zaydis Nashville green I'm
like the snacks in the survival and the
menu like they had the best food and I
just like now my bar is so high because
everywhere I go I'm like if it's not
saying these are not in Nashville I'm
going home I think that's fair cuz now
you've been spoiled well we're happy to
have you back I'm very excited to be
back I don't go anywhere for like two
weeks and then I'm hitting Denver and
st. Louis in a weekend July 19th just to
make it back in time for the challenge
with concert July 19th isn't st. Louis
unfortunately it sold out and if
anyone's not in that weekend like I'll
die
and then 21st in Denver which there are
seats left because it's my first theater
show it's not a comedy club it's the
oriental theater oh my goodness hundred
people I know so I need everyone to buy
tickets like people think I'm bald
that's crazy and I'm gonna plan like an
epic and intro intro like I can't just
walk onstage I'm in a theatre no oh my
god you need to wear like I think you
need to wear like an app like a gown no
I think so too like I think I should
take him down I think it's no longer
comedy it's it's theater well I was
really abusing my audience like for the
last two shows because I made them all
put up their flashlights while I saying
like I just want to feel like a pop star
this is the closest I'll ever get well
the oriental theater yes and I'm really
gonna make everyone in that theater put
up their flashlights that's so nice
it was also I got a video of it I'll
show ya well how was your weekend I was
getting evidential how's Darren Karp
great the shows were great we had a
great time I learned so much
well I learned so much from Darren just
about like Bravo she's a wealth of
knowledge and the episode went by in
five seconds yes she's so epic I love
her and I met her episode got so many
lessons
she's very influential she is and then
skinny how many show up was great she
changed my life one she changed my whole
like skincare routine like I've been
massaging my lymphatic nodes like things
will never be the same and to like she
has the best Instagram flow ever yeah
and we were just talking about like what
apps she uses what are her tips and
tricks like she really she like won't
take pictures with certain colors like
she won't take pictures with brown or
aren't okay so like I shouldn't take a
picture with you that's what I said but
she made my color like my hair more King
she put up this video on Instagram and
like she was talking about a vibrator
and I was just like literally dying but
a vibrator for the thing I know okay but
so what I was telling in the car is that
actually when I went to dr. Sharon Jeezy
for my post-surgery checkup she was like
you should do lymphatic massage is to
just like get the swelling down and I
was like okay sure and I like to listen
but now went it's getting up at entrance
what about it and everyone is doing it
and now I feel left out everybody's
doing so explainers me like just show me
how to do it so it's hard to do it you
should do it before your makeup because
I want to rub your makeup off and she
said it's better if you get like a
little vibrator so your hands don't have
to work as hard but you like massage out
like all there's like liquid there's
drainage and you're up on your face so
you got to massage it out and then drag
it down so that it gets down your throat
and that's why shion's go here
you're out and you down Oh massage down
and she says you do it for like five
minutes and that's why you feel it in
the back of your throat because you're
dreamily like liquid yeah that's
disgusting it but it's like the feeling
it actually makes you feel like you're
doing something right so it's nice to
feel like you're doing it right when you
start like that gaggy right as opposed
to just massaging your face with no end
yeah okay and then Friday night Rascal
Flatts concert no seriously we're
skipping right past those I think I'm
with Margot today and like it's we're
not talking about it really we're not
talking I just want to say like if if
they a come to your town like you have
to go and this is all I'm gonna say like
going in I was a little bit more excited
for dan + Shay cuz they have the new
album out there's a lot of buzz around
them like they're on the radio tequila
so like and they were just top of mind
for me and they were amazing I had every
note perfect him but Rascal Flatts are
on another level like it was indeed I
was laughing crying dancing like I
sweating like it was amazing and if you
ever have the chance to experience them
I recommend nice so there Jones Beach on
Friday
yes and I'm gonna be in the Hamptons so
because I'm trying to convince been to
like drive out cuz it's like it's in
between here in the Hamptons is we not
down he's looking on temples like it
took a family worth his whole family for
the me because Zach's my damn but I
would meet you okay okay okay have
sittin per bed convertible that's
amazing for you but I'm during the city
okay let's do it okay okay I was trying
to like talk to people in the Hamptons
like I thought I know that are gonna be
there like see if anyone wanted to go
but like I know that one person in
Hamptons is interested in this concert
and that's their problem okay wait I'm
not having an amazing experience
tomorrow and by the way we've been
getting so many requests and we really
need to get the points guy back on the
show you and I will but he's literally
so busy he's never in New York but he's
also going to heaven tomorrow we're
taking a blade together which is like a
helicopter seaplane I don't know which
one it's gonna be pray for you and our
friend Kendall did one of those like
last summer and it was a seaplane and it
like crushed in the East River even
though it was a seaplane so it takes off
in the sea and it just I couldn't get
off of the sea so to talk a little bit
so no one no one got hurt it was like a
it was a fake Sally situation yeah Holly
but so own that hurt but that's
traumatic as hell but I'm doing it why
can't one sky like there's no way don't
say don't jinx yourself I just I pray
for you
you're a very brave woman 50
minutes and it's like I just can't sit
in traffic and if the points guy does it
it's totally fine I guess I feel like
blade is like on their game on the
points Kaiser like every time it like
any airline sees the points got come on
they're like let's get over in there
let's get our good pilot yeah that's
that's good okay fine maybe a little bit
layer of protection that comes with just
like being friends at the points guy I
feel sure also my shirt my hand made by
someone in the meet and greets she was
so cute she's like I have this machine
in my house she made me a canvas bag
with like my dirty jeans logo on it like
with my news names like I go on tour
like I could just bring it with me and
I'm going to I got such good gifts I got
some gifts for you like some mugs I'll
give up or even cheat I need actually
more mugs um I got a silver Tiffany
spoon like a spoon from Tiffany Utah
Stevens whom by the way he's like Ali
met him he's a local toaster celeb but
he's also like a real-life celebi's like
he's an eliminated in the Olympics this
year he's a figure skater I thought he
was already in the Olympics no so I
believe what happens in Olympic level
he's a POJO and his partner got injured
I'm like took them out of the race which
is like so annoying for him but now he's
like working his way back for the next
four years he's friends with Anna more
poem and he was just like so epic
meeting him a guy tears Matt's I don't
know why I was just like so excited to
meet him and he exceeded all my
expectations literally he became like
literally the most popular person in the
audience because everyone knew who he
was and then we all went out afterwards
and like he like people are taking
pictures of him weren't even taking
pictures
that's hilarious and I just like and now
it was spoon from Tiffany's is he gonna
come to camp toast of course did he say
so no but like I just know you guys cam
toasts is well on its way to being a
reality tickets should be available in
the next few weeks and we just want to
let you know that we it's also in the
next few weeks so I would hope to know
it's an itchy month yes but I was we
were hoping for a mid-july ticket sale
date okay and excellent we extended it
one night because we have to like leave
Sunday morning so we figured it'd be
better if people are already missing us
on Friday that they can come on Thursday
so it'll be from Thursday afternoon to
Sunday morning which made the price go
up a little bit you'll get all the
details soon it's gonna be hard on the
list you'll be able to bunk with your
favorite toasters it's just where you
can do a shuffle bunk and read Nate
so if you're coming alone no problem I
know a lot of people are coming alone a
lot of people came over to my shows and
I'm pretty sure like someone's engaged
now to the person they met your I know I
swear
wait for real no but like emotionally so
you are lying yeah well anyways so
that's what cam dos is gonna be and it's
just very exciting so stay tuned for all
of that are you ready for the Fast Five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast girl who's reading the
comments a lot today sorry I just like
won't see if anybody says anything cuz I
lost four pounds oh and I just want to
see if anyone noticed yeah I'm on a new
diet it's called stop eating your fat
and I think it's working really buddy
are you eating and what are you eating
I'm eating significantly less sort of
the same foods well here's the thing and
this is what I was like telling everyone
like hiding is so hard for me because I
really just have such a limited palette
that like you like Olivia I wish I'd
Olivia's palette she eats like like she
enjoys healthy food like in drunk middle
of the night she'll make an omelet and
like live for it whereas like I would
rather die then even eat an omelet sober
you know what I mean
and like I don't like fish I don't like
vegetables I don't like salad I don't
like balsamic I don't like salad
dressing I don't like salad like it's
not that I not it's not that I'm making
the wrong choices is that I have limited
choices so when I do diet
I am limit it's like the three healthy
things that I like which is like
cucumbers real chicken and brown rice so
so far that's what I'm doing but I'm
really just trying to like not be hungry
and it's so hard it's so fighting your
natural instinct to be hungry I need to
get on your diet like I'm just I'm I'm
struggling and I'm not doing it for any
of the like weird sounds foundering sure
flopping
right like we're no fish flounders yeah
yeah I'm floundering rounder is a fish
right no but like when you're just like
filet like when you're just [ __ ] around
during I'm wondering on my diet well
here's the thing about dieting now that
I'm an expert cuz I've been on one for a
week Oh like I don't know I just feel
like I've never really died did before
you've never given it a chance I've
never given it a chance because like I
know there's just take me around being
fat but like I like the way that I look
especially now that I've a new neck and
I just I don't know I feel like it's
never hindered me like professionally or
socially so like I was never given an
impetus to lose weight but like now that
I'm on the road and there's so much
physicality involved like I find myself
getting tired and I know
because I'm out of shape so now it's
like starting to like slow me down
physically and now I'm like okay well it
would be better if I was a little bit
skinnier that's there yeah
do you are you inspired by at all by
your new neck I am you know I'm still
very tender and I've got to do my
lymphatic massages when I get home so
I'll figure it out but yes I'm feeling
I'm feeling inspired by Sharon Kesey
just her in general she said to me she
is she's everything yeah I did like a
whole bit about her my show like
learning my whole show was about dr.
Changizi that's so funny
I told Daren that we went to dr.
Jeremy's because of Ramona and she was
Chuck that's so funny
okay and does not need to go like I was
gonna cheat you go but like what the
hell would she had done no but you
should go just her the experience
everyone should go it's very wonderful
experience okay anyways here we are
getting into the past I story saying you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast on this
treacherous Monday morning first up a
little sports news for you guys because
this is the trade heard around the world
yeah Lebon James along LeBron James
agrees to for a year one hundred and
fifty three point three million dollar
deal with the Los Angeles Lakers so I
understand some of the repercussions
because Ben is like so invested in it's
like literally we were out to breakfast
in Chicago when the news came oh no it
came yesterday and he like stormed into
the bedroom he was like so upset cuz I
think he really thought like a part of
him really thought that he was this guy
was gonna come to the next why does he
think that was that ever possibility yes
the Knicks of early richest team in in
the league they've the most money so
like that like LeBron like he has the
rings now like now he just wants to make
money and like play basketball so like
I'm living in New York exactly we live
in like in the Midwest you know right
it's a great team I get to live in New
York you're a local celebrity or a real
celeb you get a lot of money it's a
prestigious team even though they stink
so like it was definitely one of the top
three or four teams and it's every time
the ball goes to a new team it's like
almost the next right it's always in the
running you have so been thought like
this was it and then like Larry came in
like with literal tears in his eyes he's
like I don't even in next time my whole
life like I've never got to see them be
good and like this is so disheartening
and like he was like really taking it
seriously and I was like I'm sorry like
what does this mean basically like 130
million dollars to play for the Lakers
and like I think it's because there's
less income Jack's out like he didn't
stay here I really that's what I really
think then I can understand the show bed
is just like so upset by it but this has
ramifications because like now the
Cleveland team like isn't the best now
the liquors were like fine but now
they're gonna be really good like Kobe
was on the Lakers yeah but he's what I
think LeBron just trying to be like a
Kobe this time I'm here forever said
LeBron or Kobe LeBron or Kobe and I'm
like well I don't know one of them is an
alleged rapist and one of them's not so
I'm gonna go with the one who's not um I
like the war on so much and I trust him
even when he went to the heat and that
was like Jillian love LeBron I do what I
love him from trainwreck
oh yes so funny he's so cute he's so
good at basketball and I just like a
family I just like a winner yeah I don't
know that he's a family man yes he is he
has a family that I don't know he's a
man and he's a man but I don't know if
he's a family man it's always putting
his kids and like it's bright
commercials yeah that's cute but I feel
like he definitely you know is an
athlete you think okay
how could I be I know but then Ben also
said there's major major update
Chris Bosh might be coming up retirement
okay he's the dinosaur you know what he
looks like he's literally looks like a
dinosaur no I don't know yes at all
whose neck is I'm not familiar with his
or the footlong good on the one hand
like yes the Knicks like deserve to have
their their time to shine but then
tickets will be so expensive now we can
go to Nick seems whenever we feel like
I'm gonna we don't we don't but like we
could write and we could be kidding like
in the front row for like 100 bucks I
know and and it's a it'd be too good to
be true if he came to New York and I'm
sure there'd be even more traffic like
cuz LeBron has you get to a game total
and as someone who doesn't care so much
about basketball like good for him go
live in LA go live the dream yeah but
it's like either you're a LeBron Stan
and like everything he does is like yes
or everything he does like makes you
hate him even more I think I'm a little
brown Stan because I can't imagine any
where he would go where I'd be like oh
you shouldn't have done that like to me
LeBron is like that one movie at the
Oscars that like always wins you know
what I mean like like there's one movie
every year it's just it sweeps the whole
thing like some dog millionaire but it
deserved to okay but it's not always
like that like what's one that one that
I didn't think it deserved to that's one
thing like the brothers boyhood so Brian
is not boy head this point it was bad
but no but but was it no yes everyone
disagrees you know everyone is wrong
boyhood is a terrible horrible no good
very bad movie - saw it oh my god how
grateful for the hours I still have in
my life that I didn't spend much body
added like I understood what they were
trying to do
and it's a cool idea they film these
characters over 12 years when that part
is very impressive
so that part one awards the movie itself
is terrible I can't even remember what
happened other than people we're living
other than we watched someone's boyhood
oh my god it was it was so bad anyways
but like I guess they won an award for
patience you know you know I mean if
they spend 12 years making a movie and
didn't win an award like that I'd be sad
so sad so sad
okay well LeBron James is not boy head
LeBron James is lala land like he won
everything and he deserves it if we were
called Lowell and actually didn't win
well he didn't win this last
championship I bought children in the
last championship I thought Julie off of
an Instagram ad it's really cute except
like that one is a wedding band I know
is that your wedding band well no I
bought off of Instagram no yeah it's why
it was called Adina's Jules and it was
like cheap enough but also not that
cheap that like maybe how maybe I can
wash my hands and like it not turn green
you know my Jerry talking like I got
this ring this ring and two necklaces
this one too okay a little coin maybe
for like 200 bucks oh that's that's very
it wasn't like $50 like forever 21 right
no they they look nice yeah I'm excited
for you and I'm excited for LeBron and
the whole James family to get out to the
big city
yeah like it must be nice having to move
like get a getting to move from
Cleveland to Los Angeles the brown loves
Cleveland who's rose from Paris and he's
always like standing up for it in
trainwreck okay but look for someone
who's such like a Cleveland stand why
are you leaving because I think had a
ten point or another everyone has enough
of Cleveland just like in 30 rock just
like in Hot in Cleveland do you have do
you see that episode of 30 record goes
to Cleveland with and she's obsessed
with it but then like she has to get out
Olivia Wilde's husband what's his name
Jason Sudeikis yeah and that player he
plays the boy that Sony Rocky's litter
is my shoji game you know talked about
it enough on the show today
because I haven't watched it in like six
years I need a refresh and then I want
everyone crushed maybe two years ago
with Ben and like I got him into it and
he was obsessed first of all I don't
know like I don't know even know what my
favorite part of the show is I'm pretty
sure it's Tracy Morgan Miami Jack
Donaghy oh [ __ ] it's so hard can I know
I'm Liz Lemon
no pesky yeah yeah yeah yeah you are Jay
in also in everywhere else she plays did
you hear Jane Krakowski interview on
radio Andy about jackeline from that she
was based off of a real house sighs yes
yes I didn't hear it but I acted pretty
mess
Oh own is her own rock star she doesn't
have to she doesn't have to
my birthday's soon I don't want to be
like a big birthday like annoying like
countdown so I'm letting you guys know
it's July 10th the next Tuesday and then
plan accordingly do you want to do
anything special on the show no do you
want to take off yeah that would be the
most special just you podcast so that
like you don't have to like I have no
plans I'm like honestly I'm so over like
I honestly like every time I'm a bird
it's my birthday now I'm like it's
enough like I wake up I'm like this is
too much do you know what I mean no no
that's not what's stupid tell you what
happens actually leading up to your
birthday or like stop I don't want
anything like this is too much and then
I'm your birthday or like where is
everything go by totally userview tapas
it's like where'd they bring the bay
then you wake up and you're like
everyone else is acting like it's a
regular day so like I guess I should too
I think the day after you get engaged
it's like you think it's like you're
special and the whole world is like I
don't care the day after I got engaged
the whole Scarlett Johansson flips off a
fan while out with Colin Jost
I was gonna make a crack about Colin
Jost but then I remembered that I liked
him okay Scarlett Johansson has been
spotted all over the Hamptons lately
with boyfriend and Saturday Night Live
star Colin Jost
East End regular saw the Avengers star
Thursday at Indian Wells Tavern in
Amagansett where she and Jos were in the
bar area noshing on wings and tacos but
ScarJo took a FET and so when a fan at
another local haunt tried to take a
photo a source told page six that when
they snapped a pic of Johansson and
Josie at famed watering hole shag Wong
tavern quick-thinking Johanneson flipped
the photog fan the bird choked the
patron of us wow this is very roundabout
article joke the patron to us of the
star giving the middle finger quote the
ever gracious Scarlett Johansson with
Colin Jost when we asked if ScarJo added
any verbiage to the gesture the source
says no no words needed lol ok so many
things about Scarlett Johansson because
she's in the news a lot recently did you
see that like it came out that she was
one of the people for Tom
I talked about this with Darren who is
deep in on Scientology okay also I read
a couple threads on Joe Twitter and
thence card shows like denied it but
what a child does right and Jonathan
said it made no sense because she would
never even entertain the thought because
of the Scientology component okay so but
like where is she like that come from
then I don't know
also I have to tell you so I told you
something and I told a bunch of people
in my audience but I have to tell the
rest of the world something that
happened to be able to weekend even
though the girl told me not to say but
like obviously I can't a girl team came
to my mean greet with her sister who has
dated empty and she told me the same and
I'm never ever ever like I am evolved
because once it comes out like the whole
thing could crumble so I don't even you
would resonate if you want this
affirmation you don't need me right and
I would never say it because then it
could lead to the eventual destruction
and I'm not looking forward to that like
I will never say it but just like
knowing it makes me feel cool and I was
like to the girl like did you have sex
with him and her sister was there and I
got a rose that was her like your sister
and she was like no and this her was
like you could say it I don't care I'm
when I'm Chuck so the ScarJo rumor is
not true I don't know if it's true also
I also met a girl who lives in Colin
Jost this building and I also have scar
Joel is there they don't live together
it's not weird I guess sort of the I
just feel like they're always together
but like only in the Hamptons
their relationship doesn't exist in the
city where does he live it's a girl and
she wasn't Oh literally Colin live I'll
try I don't want like blah bits but but
like in an area you wouldn't think yeah
interesting but here's the thing back to
Colin Jost and what's-his-face like when
they're both at the level of celebrity
we're like anytime you do anything like
it's gonna be news like this just seems
rude like just take the picture totally
and like she's like Kendall Jenner does
that like flips off people when they're
taking a picture of her but she's like a
name she's like a teenager yes scars
always a woman like take it in stride I
haven't been able to really look at
scars are the same ever since she caught
her hair and she never went back to long
hair she said it permanent because you
got now for like years and you know
what's so crazy is that like she was
married to Ryan Reynolds her dating was
she before Blake ya know and it's like
the good web and they probably was
they're so separated that you
remember that that's like Ryan Gosling
and Rachel McAdams they were together
right yeah but like we associate them
together like it here's how you don't
associate Ryan Philippi and yes I do
that's all I get with Ava Philippi yeah
no it's just like Leonardo DiCaprio and
Blake Lively that's crazy - yeah that's
when we oh and Giselle Leo and BA
Raphael that I mean that's where she is
yeah that's all she's now yeah and like
didn't most famous person in Israel
which isn't saying that much yeah and
also I think she's like invaded her
taxes or something she's in jail yes I
just looked at her Instagram because I
wanted to see if she didn't end up going
to jail she's not I think she just had
to pay the taxes back fair yeah very
fair choice did I have to go to jail why
didn't by Rafael I don't know I think it
was like a different level and also like
a fraud and whatnot and it's a different
country different rules totally and like
yeah I mean I'm not gonna tension of a
lot but nobody there not every case is
the same also July 4th is coming up
which is exciting for our nation but
also Angie blinds are healed
Oh people keep asking Instagram people
keep asking what empties Instagram is
saying keep saying July 4th oh so we
don't know they talked to him every day
by people try every little I forth he
reveals almost every blind item on his
site and that is coming in like two
dozen on New Year's Day - yes got it
okay I got to be up and Adam on July 4
yeah we'll post some of the craziest
ones to the toast I'm Chuck as Chuck I
didn't realize that's what it was I
wonder what he's gonna be doing with his
Instagram people keep asking me like
what's his Instagram strategy like I
don't work for him I don't know I can't
I wonder every one today what enticing
screams Johnny G is and I really look
forward to finding out and I don't know
either
no I feel good but I guess maybe he'll
do like one something is revealed
he'll post about it but then celebrities
will get tagged in it and then like his
cover will start to get blown you know
yeah it's almost like him being stuck in
like that 1997 web so it was like the
best security for him yeah and for us
and for us what we're gonna know well
speaking of the blinds don't lie
Priyanka Chopra is Nick Jonas's biggest
fan at Brazil concert you guys are
working overtime to prove the toast
wrong and I still don't believe then no
they could literally have a 30-year
marriage grandchildren white picket
fence and I still want to believe them
this is
so stupid and it's like first of all
they're not compatible in any way like
Priyanka Chopra needs to be dating an
older businessman like Nick Jonas needs
to be dating like a boy like this
they're just not compatible whatsoever
so like I was never gonna believe it and
now like what like couples in Hollywood
like work so hard to keep their privacy
where it's like Nick Jonas is giving it
away for free right look at the wedding
on the beach and now they're going to
Mumbai like stop lying no I don't I
expect this from him because I feel like
any relationship that he's in like he is
an icon and like we wanna we want to be
there for it but for her like she's so
private and like clouds of the world
wedding royal wedding Megan Marcos best
friend like Quantico I couldn't agree
more like what do you do here and maybe
it's because quantico's cancelled and
she scrambied better yeah I mean maybe
it canceled yes it is canceled 100 yes
yes that yeah that I don't know so I'm
saying maybe like this is her strategy
like maybe get him with a younger fan
base and like I have no idea
see like see her on The Bachelor they
must stop no they must have like the
more the dead embarrassing themselves no
cos really embarrassing herself which is
whole farce
she's really embarrassing herself in
honestly Nick is too because like you
they're so police's they profess because
he could date anyone anyone so catchy
that not each other you know like I get
what's in it for her I can't what's in
it for him too cuz now he's just not
more than a tweener he's like dating
like a perfect woman a woman of the
world like an Amal Clooney like she's
like but he has majority I mean no not
at oh I'm so confused by this
and I'm like getting irritated and like
honestly enews has to stop I know for a
fact that whoever runs that you news
Instagram is a toaster a hundred percent
okay I won't be Maddie you for stealing
all of our Lego but just please do me a
favor and stop promoting this
relationship like you're making it worse
and you're making them think that
they're doing a good job and you're
reinforcing that behavior and you have
to stop okay Sarah or whatever your name
is I think you might be a boy really
well whoever it is watches every TV show
on the planet good no I think they have
a team of experts and okay you guys are
like the comics team no guys here's a
post about once you're yellow what's a
reference for mantra him yeah you guys
had we have like the 90s expert I have a
spreadsheet of every TV show on every
reference uh-huh and then yeah like
there's someone who scans sometimes they
were too hard too
make a reference like work for sure but
I can appreciate it mucho mucho mucho
and I think they're doing a really good
job
except I agree you've got a layoff of
Priyanka and Nick because out of control
you're embarrassing yourselves I heard
they're looking at engaged in like
that's I heard that's too big you're
like a minute I'm like a fake website
that is speaking of a fake website you
know there's like over rumor going
around like the shitty blogs like might
be true that don't be tardy is canceled
I don't like it's true when I'm under
poetry like those fake radar yeah but
Rho yeah you calm I won't I'm not going
to waste any emotion on it until it's
coming I don't want to put it in the
universe right so when we discuss it
anymore okay
speaking of Nick Jonas and speaking of
relationships Olivia and Coco and Danny
Amendola couple up on a b-side getaway
Ibiza you don't know I'm like so not
invested in this relationship like my
emotions are invested in like a couple
other relationships at the moment that I
can't take the time what relationships
do you invest yourself in um not Danny
Amendola and because here's the thing I
like I like Olivia culpo obviously she's
gorgeous what's not to like and she
means so much to your sisters do you
mean so much my sister so I'm happy that
the joy that they bring her but that's
pretty much it you know and like it
almost bothers me like that people care
so it makes me like care less I
understand but what I do care about is
there's someone pointed out in the
trusted group there's some other trauma
going on with Olivia a couple that I
want to talk about apparently she had
fallen Arianna Falcone on Instagram what
who's like her cousin who she made like
who's her best friend and a fellow
toaster yes so I don't know what's going
on there maybe we'll have to get her to
come on for an exclusive interview but
someone pointed it out stop I'm going to
look now maybe was an accident they
haven't fought they haven't like posted
together in a while I don't believe that
please validate I mean I don't see
mother it's not there but she thought
was an Arianna Falcone phanpy maybe she
just forgot and let's see them Arianna
fellows Olivia I think they said that
she does still how did the toasters even
provide listen is there an app where you
can like follow who people unfollow no
Arianna snowfalls Lydia right some maybe
like me cause like her on following her
like wouldn't hurt
you know no but like maybe like Olivia's
in Ibiza like her finger it's possible
like just unfollowed alright put it out
into the ether let's see what happens
next okay okay if you're watching blink
once if you're okay um well here's the
thing about these two you know I ship
them left right and center but like they
broke up it was enough time I kind of
moved on and I was excited to see who
she was gonna date next and I was ready
for bigger and better things for her and
so to regress like this now you guys
have to stay together because I can't do
this that's an amazing point is that
like I forgot about it and you know what
else it is about her like the thing I
really like about following her career
is like it's just so interesting to see
how famous you can get from like being
really Instagram famous and like having
dated a famous person like being in a
pageant like she doesn't really have
like a one Talent it's like but she's
multi-talented right ya know so I'm just
like to follow her because I really want
to see how far she can take this Sherrod
that's why and so hurry but I understand
what you're saying
her being single is just like a way for
her to keep getting like she really was
put on the map by dating Nick Jonas she
was spotted with Seth MacFarlane once
like I look I'd like to see her single
because I want to see how far what she's
gonna do next to launch her into the
next level of her career so her dating
someone she's already dated who's like
really not that much of a more famous
than her like it's like net for me
that's why I'm not invested in that for
me but then it's like hey wait maybe
they really love each other and that's
cute I'm not interested in a love affair
you're not no not for a let me echo what
everyone deserves true love and I'm not
saying she doesn't deserve it I'm just
saying I'm not interested in watching it
okay well I am and I'm just upset
because now he's on the Dolphins and
they're no longer the New England
Patriots that they once became queen of
the Northeast
well the prince and princess because Tom
and Giselle okay please but did you see
will be posted on our Instagram Tom
Brady commenting on that parcel video of
like two hippos eating each other's ass
of course so disgusting did he kiss his
son with that mouth that's disgusting
that's the thing we're gonna move on
okay fifth and final story flipper flops
Christina el Moussa opens up about her
painful divorce quote I felt like I was
drowning
I hate these - well I hate she hates me
she hates him ah she aided him when they
were married and they goo boo town the
show like every time he would say
something she would literally not listen
at all and just be like I
to murder you and then he actually tried
to murder her and I can't believe they
still have a shell like HGTV is so
proper like literally like they're so
like they like for every one for every
season of every show they have there's
like one gay couple like they're so not
progressive at all they're like so
buttoned up like the fact that they
would have this like a couple stay on
their network who's like divorced there
was a murder there was like a gun they
went to the mountains but the helicopter
liked the fact that they still continued
to give them a show is wild and I
thought what they did was really smart
and that like when they're when Turk and
Kristina's relationship started to go to
hell people are like what's gonna happen
to the show they started to franchise
the show so now there's a flip and flop
flip or flop Vegas which is amazing flip
or flop Nashville Atlanta so that like
even if one of them goes away there's
still flip or flop I thought that was
genius but they never got rid of Tarkin
Christina and they continued to do the
show as a divorced couple which was so
awkward and now she gets her own show
what's her own joke I don't know but I
just heard that she's getting her own
show well good for her she's gotta bring
home the bacon
I'm gonna tarick at the airport yes oh
my god on our way home from LA
that was crazy I never thought even at
their height that the show was good or
that they were interesting or that they
made good houses and they always picked
like a really ugly houses and ugly paint
colors for the exterior and now that
like I've been given a reason to hate
them I do okay
you're allowed you can't love everyone
no you can't and I don't good well this
is what she said she said quote I felt
like I was drowning I was doing whatever
I could to stay above water and just get
through the day in the aftermath of the
gun incident the said gun incident a lot
of people were thinking what's going to
happen tark and I were so tied together
on everything real estate to show our
children our house it was so stressful
and everyone was worried that it was
going to explode oh and they were
involved in a huge online scam did you
hear about this yeah I got served a like
actually a sponsored ad on Facebook a
bunch of times to go to like this
conference to hear from tark and
Christine on how to build a business
blah blah blah and like literally they
weren't there they like scammed people's
money and like it wasn't even real look
I'm just so not down with that at all
no I I mean fair she kind of from born
uh Burnham Ari's future wife yeah but we
where do they live where did she live
they're in OC or no like they're in
Southern California Oh cute this both
still live there
okay they would pick up houses for 200
grand like on the way to work it's so
weird their whole thing I I just she she
won Real Housewives of OC one hundred
percent that's an amazing idea her in a
minute and oh my god a man a saint
really [ __ ] also did you ever hear I
remember that Audrina Patridge risk she
clearly didn't she clearly didn't we're
getting served OC premium content on
Instagram these days because Sharon
Shannon Vicki and Tamra are like the
three best friend said I know I could
have Shannon Vicki and Tamra oh my god I
can't keep my visual Shannon Tamra what
about Kelly
oh no sorry Kelly Tamra Shannon thank
you okay um I know she's the og of the
OCE
but like jealous I'm done with Nicki and
I don't think that they'll ever get rid
of her just because the nostalgia but
honestly she's not the og of those he
anymore because that was Vicki Gunvalson
Vicki fumble sin is on this season and
she's not original because I don't know
who she is I agree
I just I love Shannon Kelly Michelle I
do love Kelly I really hope she can like
she okay I just want to say because you
always say you were right about Sonja
Morgan any work because I was never
sense of so new Oregon I was a Stan of
Kelly Dodd and you hated her and I said
she was misunderstood really yeah the
first season when she was crazy I
remember I think it was like our first
ever show maybe that was right when I
was back to Dwight but right when I was
turning on her in a positive but I just
remember being like if she's on and
again like I'm not watching you know
when Ireland remember and I said a
really Shannon was being so shady when
she was like telling the waitress - poor
Kelly like double drinks when Kelly was
trying really hard not to drink like I
knew something was weird and I knew
Kelly was misunderstood and I'm so glad
I stepped by her and that she stepped by
herself cuz after the first season she
really should quit but should yeah and
now she's like I feel like she has like
least around a potential ya know I'm so
here for her speaking of Lisa Rinna I've
been watching that man I'm on the final
season I'm oh it's like so bittersweet
Harry Hamlin is in it he um he's a cool
dude but like everyone's like Harry
Hamlin Mad Men like he's in two seasons
and he's like in one scene I was gonna
say cuz I've seen like an episode with
you and like random clips on the
internet and I've literally never seen
Harry Hamlin
yeah no he's like an ancillary character
like it's not his show so
Lisa Rinna stone Harry Hamlin selling to
us to fly to Cuba see every week Emily
sauce to work and I decide I really want
to do like a line on QVC I feel like I
really know what what the kids want what
would you do and if anyone works at QVC
I've been trying to get in touch with
them and no one can get back to me
here's my official pitch sweet but maybe
like don't you don't want someone to
steal it oh [ __ ]
no but the idea is surrounded by me like
around me like okay first of all I'm the
perfect person for QVC a because like I
love to never leave my house but also
like I also need things to live and be
like I feel like QVC HSN it's like
really moving like with like the older
generation and if more kids knew about
it like they would shop on their TVs
like they shop online what's what's the
big deal to anything you have a great
personality for Jesse to like I really
know what like what what women want to
wear look I know where it's like
something is cut I know it needs like a
little spin can it like I know you know
look I just feel like I could be this
face of like this amazing QVC brand I
really feel strongly about that what
would you make I would make literally
like just the best leggings the best
genes like stretchy kimonos like just
things that like are comfortable but
also pretty and then like how to how to
maintain the chubby busy also like very
Lisa Rinna vibe but hers I think are
really target it's like a more older
audience mine would be like a chubby
younger Lisa Rinna collection heavy they
should just call it that no they should
call it Jesse because 100 percent for
like young chubby Lisa Rinna no I like
see big heavy physique cpf chubby
physique that's great CCP Claudia's
chubby fizzy whatever I don't know I'm
open I'm stinking if you work at HSN
hit me up you could be the next joy I
would love nothing
I love joy I want to have her on the
show I have so many questions for her to
I just crazy that she's like still out
there on QVC know usually when they make
movies about you it's cuz you died yeah
you're long gone but she's still like
you can see her at I just bought new
product she sells I bet around would you
buy a mini steamer
oh my god it's unbelievable he needed
that the other day I feel a little bit
of water it's really good to travel with
it's tiny and it works just like as good
as a real steamer and I can't iron cuz I
don't mean ironing board I'm always like
ironing on my floor it's so stupid you
iron well like when my shirts really
crinkly yeah and they don't have time so
we run the shower and just leave the
shirt that's that's that's that's my
version of ironing yeah College ironing
I did that once in the Hamptons and
forgot and like the bath was
I'm gonna ran over it was like this
whole big thing that you should have
done a shower yeah yeah yeah but you
know that's why I don't do it anymore
I really recommend the Joy's steamer
thanks sister what else what else again
what else did I do this weekend I so I
went to the concert to change my life
about everything after that was just
like a blur no and my feet when I got
home like I couldn't move Saturday like
I had nothing I had I was running on
anything I went downtown to the pier 17
and I was enjoying myself that I was
just like I had no fumes I'm literally
so thirsty I can't believe there's
nothing left in this cup that's so sad
and then I watch Mad Men
I watched set it up oh my god I want to
talk about it okay please um
because obviously there's so much hype
around it I really liked it I agree it's
not kissing booze and I'll tell you why
for a different audience no I'll tell
you why it's not causing this honestly
it's the same thing but kissing booth
had a better soundtrack this didn't have
any songs that like we're like hyping up
any moment yeah oh no knows where my
rosemary goes right but nobody knows but
I love the kissing booth is the
most-watched movie in the world on
Netflix no in the world what do you mean
because if they can see how many times
it's already been viewed and like it's
literally been watched more than any
movie but how can they know how many
times another movie has ticket sales DVD
sales like not watches but like you
don't know how many times someone
watches a DVD once they buy it but like
that's I'd the guy from Netflix said we
think that it's supposed to us maybe in
the world literally the quotas like I
think interesting anyways I love Zoey
Deutsch and Glen Powell she's so pretty
he's so good-looking except we're oh
yeah it was a little he was a little
nerdy anyways I really like them but
here's why it's not kissing booze it's
because they didn't have the chemistry
that Joey King and her man do because
they're really in love like if these two
actually fell in love from the movie it
would have had a little bit more spark
and it needed better soundtrack but I
really liked I really liked it and there
was a couple times I was like laughing
of cuteness especially when they went to
the Yankees game in the whole stadium is
cheering kiss to the two of them yes
well I fell asleep for about an hour in
the middle I must have missed that it
was it's really cute there
something not to like and I'm really
just glad that Netflix is bringing back
rom-coms and not every movies gonna be
the kissing with no it doesn't have to
be but I am here to support Netflix
original content me too because I'm
really getting super close to canceling
my cable bill I just bought an Amazon
fire stick oh my god first of all and
you don't to type anymore that's the
worst part of like my Smart TV is like
kitty litter just like Alexa the kissing
booth it's amazing and she plays music
and you can now subscribe if you have it
like a cable login you can get live a
live Bravo live news I don't know I
don't know why I said I have I don't
know cable still but I still oh right
the only thing that's not good about not
having people doesn't affect me right
now is Riverdale on the CW I can't watch
live but I have until October to figure
that out maybe I'll have to just go
watch somewhere else every week is about
around this week yes it's on tonight oh
I actually looks like a good episode
there's like a fake debate between the
guys they have to like talk about
themselves Colton is looking
uninterested well you know what we have
to watch because it's our job
unintrusive do not enjoy Sante and doing
your job it's my job to be a cynic and
Here I am doing an A+ job okay well I
watch for you guys because that's what I
do actually we have plans tonight so
maybe yeah well until Livia's faux
birthday yeah it's her birthday birthday
that's exciting I'm so hungry right now
and like I'm is it I don't know I didn't
we've been doing the show for five
minutes or five hundred I can't tell
it's 40 41 minutes oh I thought you were
like what the Lord no what time is it
it's 11:11 make a way straining what do
you want to be healthy I want to be help
you yes you do I'm happy okay well
that's all she wrote today you guys I'm
no I'm not um I am I got home from my
trip and like renta Theo's arms thank
you by the way for taking Theo um
nothing like an aunt Sanitas and it was
literally like the happiest reunion I
recorded a little bit of it like he
everytime I go away for a while I come
home and he cries and it's so cute and
sad and now I just had to leave him
again because Ben's going to Hamptons
but I have a job um so we're there for
the week but Ben's going like setting up
getting the car and I'll be there
tomorrow after the show
housekeeping we're doing a show today
obviously show tomorrow and then Schleif
or so though enjoy a party celebrate our
great nation that's made us Instagram
famous and no shows the rest of the week
so I don't know if the nation as a whole
has agreed which weekend was July 4th
weekend it didn't feel like it was this
thing it was assuming it's next weekend
I mean I wasn't here so it wasn't right
but no I heard people were celebrating
this weekend but I mean people said they
were like do I take the long weekend
starting Friday to Wednesday or should I
take a long weekend starting when's it
Sunday no Wednesday is something that
you have to do it after it's like you
need something to live for you know like
if you just blew your weekend last
weekend now what yeah wait until Labor
Day shoot your shot yeah oh my god you
know when you like start to get hungry
that it's like painful do you know I'm
talking about yeah oh my god I was being
such a drama queen on the way to Chicago
like I was in two news and you just like
bicep feel okay I could use it I was
buying like wet wipes I don't even know
what I need them and the vanity but
what's that the Hudson is recently their
technology cleaners like to clean your
phone not that um Margo my friend Marco
fish like I flew with her once and she
like wiped down her whole seat and I was
like now I feel like doing that too
um so just like buying [ __ ]
unnecessarily about trying I mean
because like I really have been getting
motion sickness recently and they were
the chewable like the tums like never
taken that and I was like I mean I'm
like candy like they were so good and I
got to my hotel I was like really sick
um and I could like was like exhausted
it was because they were jazzy and I was
eating so many on the plane there's
something wrong with you I didn't know
Dramamine can be drowsy they all you
have to buy non-drowsy regular formula
Dramamine is makes you tired well yeah
so obviously it works and you can't be
sick if you're asleep um ya know
sometimes like if I don't have
non-drowsy I have to take drowsy
even when I'm like going on a boat to a
party and here's him to drink your way
through it ya know I was just like so
confused I was like why am I so tired
that's and in the state as my eyes were
closing like falling asleep like right
before my show I was like a shot up I
was like so let me just not exist
the Dramamine is drowsy like I'd be like
maybe it is I didn't know like that John
me to be drowsy that's so crazy do you
know that we took the ferry to the
Rascal Flatts concert isn't that crazy
what ferry from pier 11 to somewhere in
New Jersey then we took an uber from
there to the stadium was eight miles and
then GG ferry back you just took the
whole no but took an uber back because
they were
more ferries and we were like trashed
that's crazy isn't that crazy and it was
it looks like a train like I've never
been on a ferry where it's like the
seats there's tables not like the Staten
Island Ferry right it was really crazy
and how did you even think to do that
Olivia and Zach's recommended it cuz
he's in New Jersey expert yeah he is
I would have never thought I would have
been sitting in traffic for two hours um
that's all she wrote
Thanks to everyone who came out to
Chicago shows this week I think it was
great I would love to hear feedback
because the show was still like it's
still like I change it every time I work
in progress it's a work in progress so I
I would love to see like just some
general thoughts on the show good and
bad preferably the master posted
coasters I don't know yeah this time
they are I'll think about it
he started Yelp they're the worst those
people are ruthless so if you want to
come to a show I'm hitting all the towns
all of them this year I mean this summer
um
clear the girl with no job calm denne
burn st. Louis coming up I finally got a
Boston show tickets will go on sale July
9th for patreon and then a couple days
later for for regular fokin like that's
like the show like I think you could
change that I think that show could
change my life that's really exciting
it's gonna be at like a very prestigious
theater I know I know and I've been
hyped up already I'm at hype level to
him I'm excited for you to be able to
tell people and the body can all get
excited together the boss Dean's have
been like very antsy about the show and
the tickets and I'm working overtime but
like if you guys don't buy them I'm
gonna kill you like you made me think
you were gonna buy them and like that
you have to yeah you've committed are
they well and it'll be it will all be
there yeah it'll be a family affair
we'll also we will be recording our
first July patreon episode either today
or tomorrow depending on what time
you're leaving so make sure that you
become a patron of our patreon patreon
com Sasha morning toast for extra toasty
premium content and if you are going on
a long weekend you need something for
your road trip travels and I would
recommend the patreon because also you
do get access to previous episodes and
you can just learn way more about us and
you also can get oh you'll get early
access to camp those tickets oh yeah
so it's worth it yeah for that reason
alone it's $8 it's worth it like just
don't have one coffee yeah that's how
much a club because to Starbucks like
with text and everything that's so crazy
it's so crazy
it's it's been an absolute pleasure
hangout he will see tomorrow peace
you